you know this guy Jim Cramer Jim Cramer
is over on he's on CNBC and this guy is
incredible every prediction that this
guy makes he's a market guy right he's I
think he had to show Mad Money I'm not
sure even if they have that show anymore
but he goes on these shows and he tells
people what to invest in but he always
you know I'm telling you what to invest
in but don't follow me he gets
everything wrong like there's there's a
Twitter account that just follows all of
the things that he gets wrong well just
weeks ago not too long ago maybe it was
two months ago something like that uh he
was going on and on about how great
Silicon Valley Bank is
Tucker had some fun with that
here is professional BS artist slash
dumb person Jim Cramer of CNBC telling
his viewers to buy Silicon Valley Bank
even though it was in the process of
going under this is last month
cancel don't you want
Merchant back with with deposit base
That Wall Street had been stately
concerned about
HCL Silicon Valley Bank Richie bought
one of our favorite research firms both
at Nathanson it's become less dependent
upon private equity and venture
capitalist offerings wait a second let's
try it up last year they could come back
long-term private Equity Venture Capital
let him go on away being the banker to
these invest in men's pools of capital
has always been a very good business
svb's nearly 40 rally this year is
barely a drop in the bucket
this VP is great if that guy ever
endorses anything you're doing
move to the Canary Islands change your
name because disaster's coming
look so that's why you have to have fun
with this but also why it's hard to
listen to Jim Cramer like could you
understand he was like Angry Birds
and then people listen to him
[Music]
thank you